it was an exciting first day as Rapids  got underway in Paris for the start of  the 2017 grand chest tour last year's  winner Hikaru Nakamura looked like he  was completely dead again Fabiano  Khurana  but after terrible mistake by his  opponent dr. won the game and is now in  a stone's throw of the leaderboard 2016  Grantchester a champ Wesley so was  totally busted in two of his game but he  miraculously turned lost his instant  wins to end the day in a tie for first  world champion magnus carlsen took  advantage of his opponents blunders the  score two knockouts leaving the best  player in the world to joint lead at the  top of the standings  it's been a hot summer and the  excitement is just tuning up rouse the  action live from Paris coming up next